(upbeat instrumental music)
- I've never worn matching costumes.
- I think this is the first time
I'm celebrating Halloween with my cat.
- Last year was her first Halloween,
put a dress on her, which she got off
in approximately 30 seconds.
- We put her in a little
Halloween costume,
and have her greet trick-or-treater's.
- She's a rescue story, or
I guess I'm a rescue story.
And all of this fur
are just fur sprinkles.
For, for everybody.
(lively upbeat music)
- So I'm gonna draw out of here
what my costume's gonna be, let's see.
- Lilo and Stich!
- Holy Hound and Naughty Nun.
(laughs) What!
- King Crab and Mermaid Princess.
Am I the mermaid princess?
(upbeat music)
- Look!
- [Matt] Oh my god.
(upbeat music)
- This is the most covered up
I've ever been in my entire life.
(upbeat music)
- Oh my god, Jolene, you look so cute!
(laughing) Hi sweetie.
- This is the cutest thing I've ever seen.
- Look it, you're already surfing.
Are you surfing?
(singing Hawaiian tune)
- I don't know why her boobs
are on her back, that's weird.
- It's hard to find plus sized
costumes for cats nowadays,
I think there's an initiative
to keep cats skinny.
She's a kitty with
curves, and this costume's
just a little bit snug on her.
- This costume's a good weight loss plan,
I've already lost three pounds.
- I feel like we look really cool.
- I would totally wear this
costume out with my cat.
- Matching costumes, it can come off
as borderline creepy I think.
(laughing)
(creepy instrumental music)
(metal sign creaking)